i wanted to do a video about coronavirus
because i have it and i thought i needed
to actually tell people
given the fact i put up a video about
three months ago which i will link here
complaining about the quarantine and the
economic effects that locking down the
entire world
has suicide rate just rates of
depression
job loss protests it's a disaster
so i thought it was kind of funny that i
put up that video and then actually got
coronavirus
so i wanted to tell everyone what it's
like i've had it
for 18 days so some people
get it for less but i've definitely had
it for 18 days
it started with a flu like symptoms i
thought i'd eaten something
so nausea bloating diarrhea about a week
after that
i got a mild fever 37 and a half degrees
very mild and i've had a fever for three
days
the symptoms seem to kind of go like
this so i'll be like
it's over and then i'll have one day
where i'm stuffed up bloated
achy and then no symptoms for about
three days
it just goes like this i still stand by
what i said in the other video that it's
ridiculous to lock down a country over
this
i'm surprised that it's as
mild in me as this because i've had
pneumonia three times i've been
hospitalized for it once
i've had bronchitis at least 12 times so
i thought i was more susceptible to
pneumonia
and viral infections bacterial
infections on top of that
but it really hasn't been that bad i'll
show you a clip
of what i looked like you know four days
ago when i woke up and my face was
ridiculously puffy
and so here's that clip
so i definitely have clone a virus and
this is what coronavirus face looks like
isn't it cute
corona virus you see how puffy i am
my skin is breaking out my eyes are
puffy i know scarlet's puffy too
i'm super bloated it's not the worst
virus i've had
this year but it stops
i don't know it's oh there you can kind
of see her armpit
got a little red you can't really see it
anymore but she got a rash
like everywhere and did you feel bad for
a little bit
yeah but are you better now yeah
me on the other hand i'm in like troll
mode this ain't cute
and my tongue is feels weird
so yeah it's not cute this that was i
think that was
that was almost a week ago i took that
video my face is still kind of puffy
my skin's broken out a bit i'm still
like achy
and a bit nauseous and my nose is
stuffed
and it's been a while like it's been 18
days of this so it's not
a casual like one week cold
but everybody here caught it um
my husband's symptoms were similar to
mine he was achiever i would say
my kid got it and her symptoms were a
bit different she got a rash
she got a rash under her armpit as you
saw in that video
on her hands here's some photos
so it was a bit different for her but
her main symptoms were like
diarrhea basically and
she's happy now um my dad got it and
he's in a clinic here it was a bit
unfortunate
it was like the everyone caught it
everyone in the clinic caught it
it's just it looks like it went rampant
in belgrade because they opened up the
country
completely so then they had a spike
which isn't that surprising dad got it
and because he's in the clinic and they
were worried about him and because he
had pneumonia earlier this year
already um they bombarded him with
antivirals and antibiotics
and steroids and i honestly think his
reaction to those medications was worse
than the actual virus
so he's i'm not going to get into
details there but
he's feeling better from the coronavirus
but
the treatment for the coronavirus was
absolutely
brutal um and to tell you the truth
i don't know i think that the treatment
was worse than the actual symptoms
but who am i to say
so yeah i just wanted to tell everybody
that
i still think it's ridiculous that
countries are locked down
i'm gonna have to get a t-shirt that
says i've already had it screw off
when people ask why i'm not wearing a
mask because i'm not wearing a mask for
the next two years after already having
the virus
also i have papers
which means no forced vaccinations for
me suckers
if anyone wants me to cough in a bag and
send it to them i'm here
that's a joke by the way uh so
yeah that's what's up with us peterson
family at least
part of the family has survived from
coronavirus
and still thinks that the countries
should be opened up because this is
ridiculous for a virus with this death
rate